THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
I'M GONNA MAKE A HIP-HOP ALBUM
NO MATTER WHAT.
UH, WHERE'S MY SON AT?
SHE GETS HER SON.
SHE GOES, TAKE ME
TO ANYBODY WHO CAN RAP
AND RHYME OVER MUSIC.
TAKE ME TO THEM.
AND HE'S LIKE, UH...
WELL, I KNOW
A RAPPING PIZZA GUY.
HER SON TAKES HER SON TAKES HER
TO THE CRISPY CRUST PIZZA SHOP
WHERE THEY HAVE
THE RAPPING PIZZA GUY.
HEY, THIS IS BIG BANK HANK,
SHE GOES,
HEY, I HEAR YOU CAN RAP.
OH, YEAH, I CAN RAP.
CAN YOU DO A BEATBOX?
- [beatboxing]
- NO, COME ON.
[beatboxing]
- [beatboxing]
- LIKE "F."
LIKE THE LETTER "F."
- [beatboxing]
- THERE YOU GO.
NOW, MAKE IT A BEAT.
- [beatboxing]
- ♪ SOMETIMES
I WEAR A VEST ♪
♪ AND I'LL NEVER STOP RHYMING ♪
♪ 'CAUSE I'LL NEVER
STOP TIMING ♪
♪ ALL DAY
♪ I KEEP REMINDING
♪ ALL MY FRIENDS OF...
[laughs]
LOOK, I'M GONNA MAKE
A RAP ALBUM.
YOU SHOULD BE ON IT.
WHO ELSE
DO YOU WANT TO BRING IN?
BIG BANK HANK IS LIKE,
UH, I'LL TRY TO--
YOU KNOW,
LET ME THINK OF SOME GUYS,
AND HE THINKS
OF A COUPLE GUYS
WHO ARE, LIKE,
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
HE BROUGHT IN WONDER MIKE
AND MASTER G,
BUT HE HIMSELF
DIDN'T HAVE ANY RAPS,
SO HE WENT TO A GUY
NAMED GRANDMASTER CAZ.
AND HE GOES,
HEY, GRANDMASTER CAZ,